- Hi, everyone. Welcome to re:Invent 2025.
For those that are experiencing
re:Invent for the first time,
you're in for a incredible week
of learning and innovation.
Quick show of hands, how
many of you have experienced
Agentic AI solutions in your
workplace or daily life?
Okay, so that's about a
third of the 150 so people
that are in this room.
And how many of you have
wondered about the architecture
or implementation behind
those experiences?
Okay, about about 25%.
The adoption of Agentic AI
has truly been remarkable.
At AWS, we've been privileged
to witness our customers
across industries rapidly
innovating these solutions
to solve complex business challenges
and create transformative
customer experiences
to solve complex business challenges
and create transformative
customer experiences, sorry.
However, this accelerated pace has brought
significant challenges from
architectural decisions
to production implementation,
and industry-specific considerations.
That's exactly why we've
designed today's session.
We'll share insights into
how different industries
are leveraging Agentic AI,
explore common architectural patterns,
and provide guidance on
how moving from pilot
projects to production.
We'll also examine how application
development is evolving
in the era of Agentic AI.
My name is Eric Espeseth, I
lead the solution architect team
for enterprise customers
in the United States,
for customers that are new to AWS.
I'm pleased to be joined on
the stage by Akhil Melakunta,
who's a senior solutions architect.
Jey Vell, a senior SA leader,
and Kalpana Mahesh, who is a
Agentic AI specialist leader.
Let me quickly walk you
through what we'll cover today.
We'll start with an executive
outlook on Agentic AI,
focused on the healthcare
vertical and several use cases
where our healthcare
customers are transforming
the patient care experience.
Then Akhil will dive into
the Agentic AI architecture
guidance and provide examples
of how customers in the retail
and e-commerce vertical
are leveraging Agentic AI
to transform the customer experience.
Jey will follow by exploring
the path to production
with financial service focused view.
To close out the session,
Kalpana will walk us through
the innovations of the
AI development lifecycle,
focusing on how to learn,
how learn and adapting the processes
and what's on the horizon in this space.
A common question we get
from our customers is,
should I be replacing
my Agentic AI efforts,
my Gen AI efforts with Agentic AI?
The short answer is no.
We like to say that
Agentic AI is an evolution
in the AI space in general.
Gen AI and Agentic AI are
complimentary technologies,
and that's because they are different,
they serve different purposes.
As an AWS customer, think
about how you either have used
or consider using Gen AI.
So for common use cases
and summarize information,
generate content or visualizations,
conduct translations,
or those sorts of things.
All of those are still fantastic use cases
for Generative AI,
and we still encourage
our customers to generate,
use Generative AI for
those types of outcomes.
Agentic AI is similar but different.
The primary purpose of
Agentic AI applications
is to complete specific task.
We're talking about
solving complex problems,
similar to the ones that humans solve,
particularly when the
outcomes of those decisions
are subjective and involve
talking to large amounts
of data from various systems.
Now, let's dive a bit
deeper into the difference
between Generative AI and Agentic AI
in the healthcare space.
Customers have been using Generative AI
for use cases like chatbots
in patient experience
and digital health.
In this domain, chatbots
provide self-service care triage
with proactive communication
and patient care guidance.
They also generate
patient friendly reports
and post-discharge care guidance.
Similarly, in care management,
Generative AI has been
effective in summarizing records
for registries and analyzing patient level
and cohort level records to identify risk.
It has also proved valuable in segmenting
patient populations for interventions.
In medical research and education,
Generative AI has been
instrumental in solving
clinical trial patient matching,
summarizing research publications,
and providing self-service Q&A
for medical reference documents.
We have observed Generative
AI outcomes boosting
research efforts by
automating data cleansing
and enabling cross patient queries
to identify clinical trial matches.
This diagram illustrates how Generative AI
powered by large language models or LLMs
integrate with various
healthcare data sources
to achieve these outcomes.
Now, let's see where agent AI
is being effective in healthcare.
In intelligent patient experience,
we're moving beyond basic
chatbots to autonomous agents
that actively coordinate
across multiple systems.
Pulling data from EHR, lab
results, image repositories
and scheduling systems to
create truly personalized
patient journeys without
constant human intervention.
For hospital staff productivity,
multi-agent systems
now autonomously manage
the entire clinical workflows
intelligently allocating resources based
on real-time conditions, and
even predict staffing needs
before the shortages impact care delivery,
fundamentally reducing
administrative burden on clinicians.
In supply chain optimization,
agents continually
monitor inventory levels
across facilities, predict
demand patterns using historical
and contextual data on
autonomously trigger
procurement workflows when needed,
eliminating manual oversight
of routine supply management.
What makes this truly transformative
is the agent orchestration
layer shown in the middle.
Unlike traditional Gen AI
that makes recommendations
in a single domain
requiring human approval,
these agents work together
across multiple domains,
making autonomous decisions
and executing actions in real time.
This orchestration layer
enables the shift from reactive
to proactive healthcare
operations, fundamentally changing
how healthcare systems function.
Looking at these diverse industries,
we can see a landscape rich
with untapped potential.
Each sector presents unique challenges
that this agentic technology
is uniquely positioned to address.
The opportunities extend far beyond
what we will discuss today.
Executives are already
having their teams working
on these outcomes for various industries.
What's particularly exciting
is how these solutions can be tailored
to industry specific needs and use cases
while leveraging common
technological foundations.
The most innovative organizations
are already exploring these frontiers,
creating competitive advantages
through novel applications.
The question isn't whether
these opportunities exist,
but rather which organizations
will move quickly
to capture them and
define the next generation
of industry solutions.
While these opportunities are compelling,
successful implementation
isn't guaranteed.
As we can see here,
Gartner projected over 40%
of Agentic AI projects will fail by 2027
due to escalating cost,
unclear business value
or inadequate risk controls.
This is precisely why
the rest of this session
we have focused on taking
a strategic approach,
keeping the value model at the center,
and offering available solutions on AWS
to achieve agentic outcomes
at enterprise scale.
And what is our vision
for Agentic AI on AWS.
AWS's vision is to be
the best place to build
and deploy the world's most trusted
and useful agents, enabling organizations
to reimagine their
business with Agentic AI.
We at AWS are working with customers
to transform these ideas into agents,
complexity into autonomy
and effort into outcomes,
empowering organizations to deploy
secure, reliable Agentic AI at scale.
Now, Akhil will walk you through
the architectural guidance
to build complete Agentic
AI solutions with retail
and consumer packaged
goods industry focus.
- Thank you, Eric. Great insights.
To understand a well-rounded
architectural guidance
when you're building agentic solutions,
it is important to start
off by understanding
what it takes for an
agent to be functioning,
different approaches to use
agents for different use cases,
and what are the common
patterns when you try to combine
multiple agents to
accomplish a task for you.
So let's get started.
So the next part of this session,
I'll be using retail and e-commerce CPG
as an industry example
to share my point of view
on architectural guidance.
So you can understand to help,
you know, technical aspects
to your real world examples
and most of the examples
and aspects that we talk
here, you can go back
and even map it to your
respective industries as well.
So what makes an agent function?
What are the basic functions for agent
to be performing, right?
So at the core of it, agent
uses an LLM for reasoning.
To start off, when you design an agent,
it is important to set
a goal for an agent.
An example for a goal can be this agent
is a customer service agent,
supposed to solve a
query within two minutes
within an average customer
satisfaction rate of 4.5.
That can be a goal for you to start off.
It is also important for
agents to have access to tools.
MCP servers are best example,
so you can extend
capabilities of your agents.
Memory is also very critical
for accuracy and performance.
You want your more both short term
and long term memory
accessibility to your agents,
so your agents can both
store recent conversations
and also results achieved
for faster performance and accuracy.
And at enterprise scale, it
is critical for your agents
to be able to access your enterprise data.
So you can have your
agents solve the problems
that are very specific to your business.
Unlike any software system,
it is important for agent
to have an end-to-end observability
and guardrails built on it,
so you're continuously
monitoring the performance
and how agents are
operating for your business.
So now, let's take a look at how,
and with a basic agent
can help solve a problem
in a retail space.
So let's say a retail e-commerce customer
is trying to build a purchase system
where they're trying
to address a user input
and this user has asked a
question about a specific product,
which most likely means
they're trying to purchase it.
Can one agent that we just spoke about
with all the basic agentic
functions solve this problem?
Definitely, yes.
But is it performant enough
that you're tasking single agent
to do all the work?
In this case, you would want
to look up who the customer is.
Do you have that product in the inventory?
What is the nearest store to purchase?
These are multiple, you know,
steps from a single prompt
that you're expecting the agent to solve.
Does it make sense for one agent to do it
or a series of agents
helping this one single agent
to do it in parallel, right?
It's just more performant.
You want that agent to
go look up the customer,
authenticate them, look up your inventory,
whether if you have that product.
Do you have any promotion
going on for the same user?
Or you know, and then
what is the nearest store
that they can go and purchase?
When all of these agents are in action,
a well-rounded response
would look like this.
You have authenticated who the user is,
given them a recommendation,
some promotion that is
very specific to that user,
and then a nearest store
for a better experience.
So that is the pattern
that we have seen customers
using agents so far,
more reactive in nature.
You know, people doesn't like
chatbots so much anymore.
But we have seen a
foundational shift in how
the customers are using agents now.
They're moved on from reactive agents
to more proactive and autonomous agents.
So autonomous or proactive
agents are act on their own,
doesn't wait for a user
input like a reactive agent.
So you are, you know,
pricing is a best example
to understand autonomous agents
because if you're trying to
dynamically price products
for your platform, it would
make sense for your agent
to act autonomously, right?
But still, if you're from
a retail space, you know,
pricing is not as simple as
one agent can do this task.
Oftentimes, our customers
have teams of people
accomplishing pricing challenges.
So this is usually a team that would bring
a pricing strategy to a platform.
Now, to understand
multi-agent collaboration.
What if we solve this
problem using multiple agents
coming together, right?
So before we get into understanding
multi-agent collaboration,
let's start with a basic understanding
of how agents communicate with each other.
So for agents to
communicate with each other,
agents use what's called
an Agent2Agent protocol.
It is an open standard protocol for agents
to create an abstract layer
when they communicate
with each other, right?
So this protocol solves the basic problem
of interoperability between agents.
So no matter what framework
you develop an agent,
another team within your organization,
another agent can talk to
it without understanding
what is actually happening
within your agent.
So this protocol actually facilitates
transport agnostic communication.
So whether it is a HTTP with
a JSON-RPC sample request,
or for a gRPC request for
high performance use cases,
or a simple rest method
for web applications,
you can use this protocol to
communicate between agents.
So now, let's understand
going back to the pricing
platform challenge, right?
So my pricing platform challenge,
I have my market intelligence team.
So I would want to design
my market intelligence team
with an orchestrator agent
that sits on the top,
that can use multiple agents
who are specialists in their own domain.
So for my market intelligence,
I want another agent acting
as a competitor price scraper
going out and looking
up for competitor prices
and making, you know, helping
my orchestrator agent.
So in this case, if I'm trying
to price a specific product,
I want my orchestrator agent
to use multiple other agents
that specialize in their own task
and call them as a callable functions,
almost use them as tools.
So in this pattern of
using other agents as tools
is called agents as tools.
It's a common pattern
that we see customers use.
Now, let's look at how would you want
to dynamically price your customers.
So I want my agents in
for this specific use case
to be able to segment my
customers based on their historic
history of, you know, number of purchases
that they have made.
So if somebody made more
than a thousand units,
I want that customer to
be segmented in a way that
that request is routed to
a volume discount agent.
So where the notes of the
agents are deciding the path
of the communication between agents,
this pattern is called
dynamic customer pricing.
So if you have a use
case that would require
your agent notes to decide
how you want to communicate
between your agents,
this pattern is better suited for you.
Now, about actually approving those prices
that you have determined with, you know,
with the analysis so far.
So when we strategize approving changes,
I would want my agents to act like peers.
I want them sharing a
common knowledge base.
I want them sharing a common memory
where they're making their
decisions based off it
and sharing those decisions
back to the other agent as well.
In this case, all the agents here
are sharing a common memory
and they're sharing their
decisions back into that space
and acting as peers, not making a decision
in a hierarchical fashion.
Now, with that changes being,
you know, approved with,
you know, this flow,
how would I push those
changes into my platform?
Pushing changes into platform
is more deterministic in nature.
I would have my base cost agent
determine what is the
base cost of a product.
Now, with all the analysis
that we have, you know,
drawn from all the analysis
with all the other agents,
I would have my market position of
how I want to price that product.
Now, once that is done, I
would want to apply those rules
to actually push those
changes and validate them
before I do that.
This is very deterministic in nature
where one agent is
operating, getting an output
and sending that as an
input to a second agent.
So for any use cases
where you have a very
deterministic workflow,
you can use what's called
a workflow pattern.
Return order management
is another best example
in this space where the
workflows are very pretty defined
of what happens in a sequential fashion
and workflow pattern better
suits in those use cases.
Now, let's bring
everything together, right?
So we have this multiple teams
using different patterns together,
solving a complex problem
for an autonomous proactive
agent to strategically price
for a price items for a retail customer.
Here is the critical insight.
These patterns are not mutual
mutually exclusive, right?
In real world, when we
work with customers,
oftentimes it is a composite architecture
that our customers adopt.
Even in this specific case,
I can have my dynamic pricing agent flow,
use a graph pattern, but even within that,
I can have each individual agent calling
other agents as tools.
So it is oftentimes a
composite architecture
that will work for you.
So just, you know, you have to come up
with an architecture that is better suit,
that better suits your business case.
Most customers with that level
of architectural guidance
will get to a very
successful pilots, right?
So pilots, when they try
to move to production,
a whole new set of
challenges starts to arise.
So Jey is now going to take
us into his next section
where he'll walk us through
his view on path to production
and how we can accelerate it.
Jey?
- Thank you, Akhil. Welcome.
Path to production.
We are going to cover
a couple of things in
as part of the path to production,
we are to start business value model,
production challenges,
some of the guardrails
to avoid those production challenges
and some of the matrix
to do the evaluation
of your production workload.
That said, I am Jey Vell,
this is path to production.
You'll see this pattern
that's happening now.
We are talking about different vertical.
Here I'm talking about finance vertical.
Raise your hands if you're
from the finance vertical
or something to do with finance.
Amazing, around 20% of the
population. Awesome, good.
And the 40% stat, again, this
is something from Gartner.
Gartner predicts by 2027, 40%
of the finance institutions
going to use AI agents to
automate their workflows.
So that's it. Let's see where
to start and when to start.
Start right now and where to start.
It's always good to start
with the business problem.
Talk with your business
owners, line up business owners
and ask them what's the
business problem they have.
And then from there
onwards, look backwards
to meet that business
need and build a pilot
and then you can move into production.
We talk about the business value.
Let's see how to build a
business value, a value model.
And I'm gonna walk you
through a framework here.
In the end, you can take a screenshot.
Again, here, I'm gonna talk
about some of the cost elements,
also some of the returns.
And then we can see the ROI.
Then we can take this to a CFO
or any of the line of business owners
and get their sponsorship.
So when you build a any
agent, first of all,
the first cost is coming
from the model API access.
Akhil clearly explain you like
even for any agent to run,
you don't have the LLM large
language model behind it.
To access that, there'll be
a cost involved, it's 25%.
The next cost is model optimization.
Imagine you are running a
model, you get some good output,
now you want to fine tune the model
and then now you wanna do more work.
So that's where this cost comes from.
Another one where to run these models,
you need infrastructure.
That's where this cost is coming from.
The next one, this is very
important, data strategy.
What is the key difference
between an agent versus Gen AI.
Agentic AI agent versus Gen AI.
You can use your own data with agents
and again, how to use your
data, where the data exists
and what transformation you do.
All these things come as
part of this data strategy.
Next one is talent slash development.
Again here, your development
team slash how to coach them
and upskill them.
All these things come as per this cost.
Last but not least, operations
and support and ethical AI.
Again, in the financial industry, GDPR
or in the healthcare, HIPAA,
all this comes together.
How to build those governance patterns
as part of this model?
And that's going to cost you.
So this is some of the cost model,
but then let's dive into
the return or revenue part.
Again, there's some direct
and indirect revenue.
The direct revenues could be,
think about you have some
agents, you charge each agent.
When you access, you charge per access.
That's one way of charging
or getting some revenue back.
The end of the one is you may also have
the subscription model,
like, you know, for a month,
I'm gonna charge, we are
gonna charge this much.
That's the end of the way of getting
direct revenue from agents.
There are some indirect revenue.
Like for an example, if
the sales revenue goes up
because of these agents,
that's called indirect revenue.
Then on top of all these
things, there are some returns
that you may put a dollar
quantity on top of it,
but they're very valuable.
For an example, enhanced
customer experience.
Imagine you put a bot on your website
and customers go there and ask a question.
They get a really solid response.
Now, customers love your app.
Right there, you increase
the customer experience.
Another one is boost employee productivity
or especially think about
like a call center agent,
actual human being.
They have a AI agent next to
them and they ask a question
and they understand the person calling,
but calling is what they need
and what they had in the past,
so now, they can make a
really good recommendation.
That's how we boost the
employee productivity, right?
So all these come under returns.
Now, what's going to happen?
We have this cost and the returns.
Now, we can find the ROI,
create a business case
and propose that to our CFO
or other business owners,
so we can get the business sponsorship.
So now, I'm going to walk you
through a sample use case.
Again, this may vary
customers to customers,
but I'm giving you a sample example
what we observed in the past.
For any given scenario,
we have some assumption.
This is a, I'm picking up an example
from the finance vertical,
like an investment advisory agent.
For that agent, imagine you
have 10,000 queries per day.
This is for both human agent and bots.
In that, we have 50% of the
volume being handled by bots.
Now, imagine the human cost is,
I'm just putting a number
here, $30 per hour,
but then bots, obviously
cheap, 10 cents per query.
If that's the case, what's the ROI?
The ROI is 10.8 million annual
savings plus some new trades.
What that means?
As we use these agents, you
can scale out and scale in
so that there will be some new trades.
Plus, there'll be some cost reduction.
You can see that obviously,
agent cost is very low,
so there'll be some cost reduction,
plus some customer experience.
Think about that again,
bot or even customers
are directly talking
with the bot of agents.
They'll get some better experience,
so your CSAT score goes up.
Plus, new customer
conversion also goes up.
Finally, employee productivity.
Like again, this could be
coming from call center agents
or even developers.
If you put some tools
with your developers,
when they write a quote,
their productivity can go up.
Plus some, you can also give the employees
so that human beings, some complex tasks.
Agent can do the mundane tasks.
So this is sample business
model we build, right?
So imagine you build this business model
and with Akhil's guidance,
we build a nice pilot.
So what is next? We need
to move to production.
So before we get into
the actual production,
I want to walk you through
some of the challenges
that you face in actual production itself.
So you have the pilot ready,
what's the first challenge
especially in the finance industry?
Performance.
We have millions of transactions
and we need them in millisecond timeframe.
How do we get that? That's
the biggest challenge.
What's the next one? Scalability.
Between 8:00 to 5:00,
especially in the trading floor,
agents should go up and in
the evenings it can come down.
How to build that?
Next one, security.
Each and every agent may
have its own security,
but then how to establish a
security between those agents.
Underlying data, all
this come as a challenge.
Another one is context.
This is very important,
especially in the agentic workflow, right?
One agent may have some context,
it may need to understand.
And then when customer
talk with the agent,
they may give some basic context,
but they don't have complete
information about the customer.
But then how do you go
and find other information
so it can give a customer
a concise response?
That's one of the biggest challenge.
And then this is the
important part, governance.
Again, we talk about
all these GDPR, HIPAA,
all these things.
How to build a concise governance model
across all the agents?
So these are some of the
biggest challenges we face
across Agentic AI applications.
But then in the Agentic AI agents world,
there are some specific challenge.
That's called agent silos.
Raise your hands if you
heard about agent silos.
Wow, around five, 10%. That's awesome.
So I'm going to explain you
what is agent silos first,
but then we can get into the agent silos,
some of the challenges.
So again, if you think
about the financial trading flow, right?
There'll be a market analysis agent,
there could be a trading execution agent,
there could be a risk management agent,
and there's the actual
human agent sitting there
or human trader sitting there.
They're gonna use all
these individual agents
to get some information
so we can finish the actual trade, right?
So with market analysis
agent, imagine I'm the trader,
I'm going to ask market analysis agent,
"Hey, find this specific share.
How is the social media
is talking about them?
Can I buy this or not?"
We get the whole sentiment from them.
But then we go and ask the
trading execution agent,
"Hey, I want to get this share
at this price, this volume."
That if this agent is
going to execute that,
and then I'm gonna go to
the risk management agent.
Imagine Eric, come and ask,
buy these, all these shares
and Eric wants to have
this specific risk score
that he want to manage.
If that's the case, I'll specify that one
and find the right mix
of the shares, right?
So the key here is each and
every agent is doing its own job
and writing the data,
using their own services
and writing in their own location.
It's fine for the timing
because I am the human
agent doing all this work.
They don't need to talk with each other.
Let's go to a little bit
more complex situation.
Now, we get a really good output.
People are happy, build more agents.
Guess what?
I'm gonna put some
portfolio management agent,
strategy agent, then risk management,
also communication agent.
Guess what?
The communication agent need
to talk with other agents
to get some information
so they can talk with the end customer.
This is where challenge comes.
If you have these individual
agents, write the date,
access their own services,
write in their own locations,
now, they cannot talk with each other.
This is what call agent
silos. Think about it.
That said, let's see what are
the challenges of agent silos?
Like I mentioned earlier, one
of the thing is integration.
Market analysis agent and strategy agents
need to talk with communication agent,
so it can be communicated
to the end customer.
That's where the integration comes in.
Another one is security.
When Akhil's team build its own agent,
they use some specific security services.
When Jey uses, he use some
specific services, right?
Now, how do you build a
comprehensive secretary passion
across all the agents so they
all can use the same services
and build a governance pattern.
That's one of the biggest challenge.
The next one is data inconsistency.
This is again, comes like, you know,
one agent writing into one location,
other one writing into another location.
Now, they both may have similar data
but different timeframes.
Now, that's where the data
inconsistency comes in.
Another one is scaling.
Again, like I mentioned
earlier, again, this scaling,
you can think of kinda
like inefficient scaling.
What's going to happen is you
ask this communication agent
to do some work and then
there's a risk management,
there's a market analysis agent.
They all are doing some work,
but they're not sharing
any data among them.
So they're gonna scale in their own,
they're gonna use all the
services, whatever they want.
They're not using anything
across each other.
So they're inefficiently scaling,
which is not good either.
So that said, let's see
how can we overcome all these challenges.
So again, this is a sample
of production application.
Again, in the end, you
can take a screenshot
of this application, how it looks like.
So if you think about
any agentic application,
we first start with it, top
level or application level,
application layer level, where
we are going to have a web
and mobile app where you
can access the agents.
Also, you might do some IDs like Kiro.
I love Kiro by the way.
So it'll help you to develop
the applications very fast
and then there might be
some chat interfaces.
It's getting more and
more popular nowadays.
If you want to talk with agents,
chat interfaces in a cool
way to access agents.
So what we should do first?
We need to authenticate.
So to authenticate with agents,
we can use Amazon Cognito, a great service
or you can use any of
the authentic services,
authentication services.
Once you authenticate with the agents.
The next thing is we have
agents and MCP services.
You might heard about MCP services,
but again, this kind of like
a services that use a protocol
that you can access outside tools
slash data sources with agents.
That's what MCP services are.
And then underneath that, LLM comes in,
large language model.
Again, you can use any
large language models
that come by Amazon, AWS.
I mean, talk to the associates architects,
they'll give you, they'll tell
you a list of all the LLMs
that you can use.
Again, to access those LLMs,
AWS, Amazon offers our Bedrock.
It's an API service, you can
access any of those LLMs.
Once you access those LLMS
and build your PoC or pilot,
what is next, move into production.
That's where AgentCore comes in.
If you want to deploy
your agents in scale,
you can use AgentCore.
Not only that, there are so many of that.
I'm going to talk, walk through them
while I'm opening up the slides.
So what is the next layer? Semantic layer.
What is this?
Imagine you have your LLM ready
and you wanted to use your own data.
You cannot just use your data as it is.
You may need to do some data
manipulation, some ETL job.
Plus, you need to create
some new connectivity
between those data.
So agents can use them as it is.
That's where the semantic layer comes in.
You can use services such as AWS Glue,
it'll do some ETL work for you
or Amazon Neptune database
to create some graph
or connectivity between the data.
That's where the semantic layer
comes in. So what is next?
Guess what? Data.
Again, under the hood,
everything driven by data.
You might think, oh, we need
a data lake immediately.
Guess what? No, you don't
need a data lake for this one.
Obviously, you can say, if
you have a data lake, amazing,
you can use it, even if you don't have it.
Still, if you know what
is your data, where it is
and how do you need to transform that
to use your agents, that's enough.
So have a comprehensive
list of all the data sources
and all these changes and
with that, you should be able
to build your agents and move forward.
So once you have all those things done,
your application's ready.
Now, you want to observe
across all the layers.
And again, AgentCore offers functionality.
You can observe not only
across different layers
but also inside your layer.
Imagine your market analysis agent
wants to talk with communication agent
and what's happening between those two.
You can observe using
the observative framework
that offered by AgentCore.
After all, security is
one of the top priority
for Amazon AWS.
So guess what we could do.
When your customers make a call,
imagine if Kalpana has made a call to buy,
say a hundred shares
from AWS, Amazon, right?
If that's the case,
what's going to happen?
Kalpana gets a dedicated session level
security for her session,
which means there won't be any data leak,
that any data leak that's
offered by AgentCore again.
So that said, we talk about
the production workload.
Now, we're going to talk about
some of the evaluation
techniques slash matrix.
Last year, if I ask you,
hey, how many evaluation metrics you have?
You might say five or six.
This year, we have 20.
Next year, who knows?
It might be 100.
The reason I'm telling you
is all these are not like,
there'll be a lot of metrics here.
But for your vertical it varies.
And also, you may have your
own custom metrics as well.
Especially for the finance,
I'm gonna talking about
three important metrics here.
One, accuracy.
When you make a transaction with a bot,
hey, I want to buy this many shares.
This price point, it should be
that. We cannot change that.
So that's where the accuracy comes in.
The second one is robustness.
What does that means?
When you train your model,
you use your training data,
models behave just fine.
But when you move to production,
we have some real world data there.
But still model needs
to be at the same way.
That's for the robustness.
The last one, this is one
of my favorite things, tone.
So what does tone means?
Like if you think about any bots
that you interact right away.
Like if you can think
of like it's a bot voice
and all those things, you will never get
trust from that voice.
But when you build a
financial advising agent,
it should have a voice,
not only just convincing,
but also data driven.
How do you build that?
That's the end of the metrics that we use.
So that said, I talked
about where to start,
also, how to build a business value,
what are the different
evaluation techniques,
production, workload, all those things.
But now, I'm going to hand out to Kalpana.
She's gonna talk about some
of the cool innovations.
She has new development lifecycle.
So that's it, Kalpana, floor is yours.
- Thank you, Jey. Hi, everybody.
How many of you have done something today
for Cyber Monday shopping on amazon.com?
Only one person. Oh, couple of people.
Okay, awesome.
So you know, we've been
talking about agents across
multiple industries, healthcare, retail,
and financial services.
Now, let's make it
super personal and real.
How many of you are aware of Rufus,
which is an agent that sits on amazon.com?
A few people, few people.
Okay, I use Rufus all the time
and it's super helpful for me as an agent.
And now, I have Rufus even
watching prices for items
that I really care about and alerting me
when it hits the right price
that I wanna buy it at.
So it's a very proactive agent for me
that watches amazon.com on
my behalf and does actions.
Now, how much do you think,
Jey talked about, you know,
if I had an agent that's a bot
that's helping my customers,
it could enhance a
customer experience by 15%.
How much more likely
do you think people are
to buy a product if
they engage with Rufus?
Just throw out some numbers.
What percentage do you
think people are more likely
to buy a product once
they've engaged with Rufus
versus not engaging with Rufus?
Throw some numbers.
80%. It's 60%, 60% more likely.
So if you've engaged with
Rufus, you're 60% more likely
to actually complete the transaction
versus if you haven't engaged with Rufus.
And it's projected to make
at $10 billion impact,
incremental impact on dot com for us.
So having Rufus as an agent
and people engaging with
Rufus is going to bring in
projected additional $10 billion with a B.
So that's how powerful
agents can be in real life
if they are doing all of the things that
my colleagues talked about,
they have the right voice,
they're secure, have the right tone,
are able to give you accurate answers,
are performant and scale.
I mean, it does us no
good if Rufus comes back
in five minutes and tells me something,
I moved on to something else, right?
It needs to be performance,
it needs to scale.
Hundreds of thousands
of requests every second
and Rufus needs to scale
across all of them,
but in a very secure way.
So we've talked about
multiple industry use cases.
What is top of mind for XX
across all of these industries?
It's not specific to a certain industry.
You know that executives
across all these industries
are very concerned about
speed of innovation.
That's one of the things
that's top of mind.
But how do I innovate at scale and speed
while keeping my ROI front and center?
Because it has to still
produce business value.
If I did Rufus just
because it's a cool toy,
that's not gonna go very far.
I need Rufus to actually
deliver business results,
like $10 billion of incremental revenue
for it to make sense for me to invest
and do all the performance and the scaling
and the security and
the governance, right?
But innovating at speed while
delivering business value
is top of mind across all
industries for executives.
At the same time, how do
I get my people educated?
And if agents are going
to be my teammates,
not just tools in my organization,
how do I integrate agents
into the organization?
What will that org
design look like, right?
That's again, top of mind for
executives at all industries.
Processes, Jey talked about responsible AI
and Akhil talked about the architectures
that you can develop for a very secure,
responsible agentic system.
And security and trust
as a technology platform
across all layers of
your agentic development.
Whatever your architecture
that you're building,
it's extremely important.
So these are some of the key areas
executives are very much concerned about
and bringing agents to production
in a very responsible way.
Across all of these concerns
and all of these use cases,
we talked about speed
of innovation, right?
So how do we transform
traditional development approaches
using agents to build agents, right?
So that's the key here.
How do I take advantage of Agentic AI
to put my net new agentic
innovations into production
regardless of any industry?
And how do I reimagine
that development lifecycle,
not just make incremental
progress, but how do I transform
and reimagine the whole thing?
And that is what we're
talking about in terms of
future of software development.
We're all very familiar
with traditional programming
with software development lifecycle, SDLC,
they're very familiar with that.
But in a very short three,
four-year time span,
traditional programming has
been dramatically disrupted
where we've gone from code completion
to chat-based programming.
Everybody's doing vibe coding now,
but in the future, we
anticipate AI clusters
and AI fleets to be helping
our development teams.
Now, what you see on the right hand side
is a very hierarchical
imagination of agents coming into
and becoming teammates on your Dev teams.
But really, what will happen
in reality is more a swarm,
a very decentralized
agentic groups of things
that are happening along
with human collaboration
to bring something to forth.
That's really what we envision.
But the reason it's shown is hierarchical
is to get conversation going.
When people see org
design, which agents in it,
it gets a conversation started.
And executives are like,
"How do I think about
agents in my organization?
What do I do about KPIs for those agents?
Do I measure them just like humans do?
And what do I do with comparison?
And how do I account for ROI?
What's my cost going to be?
What should the value that
I should derive from them?"
They all have calculations
for teammates, right?
How do I do the same things for agents?
It's a great conversation starter,
but it gets people thinking.
So AI-DLC is the same thing as SDLC,
but doing it with AI
in every way possible.
How do I get agents and AI
injected into my development lifecycle?
To build my net new innovation
is what AI-DLC is all about.
It's a methodology, not
necessarily a product or a service.
So regardless of what service, what tool,
what product you're using,
you can always adopt
this AI-DLC methodology
to help speed up your innovation.
Again, goes to speed of innovation
and doing it the right cost
and bringing agents into
your development lifecycle
for your net new product.
It could be a net new software
product you're building.
It could be a workflow that
you're trying to automate
that helps with employee productivity
within your organization.
It could be a customer service agent
that you're putting in place.
It doesn't matter what
you're trying to do,
but if you bring in a AI methodology,
AI development lifecycle
methodology to it,
you are going to automatically
speed up your innovation.
And that's the fundamental thing
that we're trying to do with AI-DLC.
And there are three phases to AI-DLC.
The first phase is inception.
This is where you are
kind of thinking through
what the product is going to be.
How am I going to develop the product?
That's the fundamental thing in inception.
And then construction is
when we are going to get
into active construction.
This is where you're building
your net new innovation.
And then operations is you
have to deploy it at scale
and get it productive, right?
So let's look at how this works
and what the roles and rituals are.
How many of you are familiar
with agile development
in your firms?
Majority of you, majority
of you're very familiar
with agile development.
So you understand what
roles and rituals are.
So how do we take those roles and rituals
that you're very familiar with SDLC
and how do we change it
and alter it for AI-DLC
is what we're gonna look at.
So remember we talked
about the inception phase.
This is where you have this large intent
that you're going to go after.
Maybe you're building a net
new product, a net new project,
whatever you're trying to do.
So what is the intent of that?
And then you wanna
break it down, you know,
in the old style would
call it epics, right?
Here, we're going break
it down into units.
And how do we do that? That's
the key thing with AI-DLC.
It's not just,
oh, I just changed the
word from epic to unit.
That's not what it is.
It really is how do I use
AI in my inception phase?
So I am not the one writing the units.
I have the large intent and
I am going to get agents
and AI to write the units for me.
What is a task to be performed?
What are the features that I need?
And you do, you prompt the
agent to give you those answers.
So AI is actually doing
your units for you.
It is not a human doing it. So
what's the role of the human?
What's the product owner?
What's the development team
doing with AI in inception?
They are guiding it, they're reviewing it.
So that's how you get the speed.
The next phase is actual
construction and development.
Here you're doing mob
programming and mob testing.
Again, the development team
is not actually writing the code.
They're prompting AI to write the code.
And that's the key here.
So your job is to prompt review, redirect,
prompt, review, redirect.
And so, you go in that loop.
And you will see that we're
not doing sprints anymore,
we're doing bolts.
Why?
It is really specifically
conveying speed of development.
Sprint as fast as you can sprint.
If you're Usain Bolt, you're
really bolting, right?
You're not sprinting.
So that wasn't meant for Usain Bolt,
but I'm just making something,
some correlation for it to stick.
So you really are at
lightning speed moving forward
with your development and your testing
and it's an iterated loop.
You could see how each
bolt goes into a loop
where you've got the code, you prompted,
it's given you a code,
agent is going to get you
the test units as well.
AI is writing the test cases,
it's testing, confirming,
and then we're going in
that loop again, right?
So you get through development
and then you're going to go do deployment
where product owners, developers,
and AI are again, involved.
But again, for deployment,
infrastructure as code,
AI, agents helping you deploy
what you've produced as well,
what you've developed.
So that is what AI-DLC is
where the primary focus is
not humans doing the tasks,
but how are they gonna
get AI to do the tasks
and how are they prompting,
reviewing, redirecting,
and going in that loop.
That's the key.
And what can you really achieve
by using AI-DLC versus SDLC?
That's a good question, right?
Here's a customer, Dhan,
who took their existing Jira backlog,
whatever that they have in Jira
and used AI-DLC against
their Jira backlog.
So this is not for a cutesy net new,
brand new development only project.
AI-DLC is not only for,
oh, what's a net new idea?
I have no tech debt.
I am starting from a blank sheet of paper
and then I will deploy AI-DLC.
It's great, it'll work for that as well.
But we know the reality
in most enterprises,
we already have running projects right now
that we want to speed up, our
net new projects we wanna add,
features we wanna add
to existing products.
That's the reality of life.
So the question is, can
I use AI-DLC for those?
Absolutely, you can use AI-DLC for it.
It's a methodology that we
come and teach your Dev teams
on how to do, where we walk,
walk the product owners, the dev teams,
and the test teams on how to use AI-DLC,
adapt it as a methodology
using your existing tools,
existing services, existing
backlog that you have.
Just using this methodology,
how can you speed up?
And with Dhan, we were able
to take what was two months
of development using their
existing agile methodology
that they had put in place.
And we shared with AI-DLC
how they can deliver it
in two days instead.
So that's the kind of
revolutionary re-imagining
transformation we're talking about.
It's not incremental, it's
not going from, you know,
two months to maybe I
could cut a week off.
It truly is taking two months
of your existing backlog
and how do I deliver it in two days.
And that's what this
methodology teaches you.
So in closing, right?
We have seen multiple industry use cases
across healthcare, retail, finance.
We have seen what are the
key architecture patterns
that you wanna adopt
depending on what you want
that agent to do and how you
use an orchestration layer
to bring all these agents together,
where you're using multiple
architecture patterns
for the individual agents,
but then working as a team,
how do you bring that together?
We talked about how to go
from pilot to production
and what are the key things
you have to keep in mind.
And then what is a methodology you can use
to speed everything up, get
to your innovation faster
and get to your ROI faster.
Hope that was very helpful.
We have a few minutes left.
We can take some
questions if you have any.